aux haïtiens il était de me suivre est
aujourd'hui je vous parlais d'une
entreprise française que j'ai rencontré
il ya de ça déjà quelques mois lorsque
j'étais au csa las vegas j'ai attendu
pour vous en parler
je trouve qu'ils ont un système qui
pourrait vraiment être révolutionnaire
et je pèse bien mes mots pour recharger
nos smartphones nos objets connectés
nos appareils photo dans une hauteur
l'ensemble de votre parc high-tech cette
société s'appelle énergie secouèrent je
vous invite à découvrir et puis a marqué
tout ce que vous en pensez en commençant
dites moi si vous trouvez cette techno
intéressante
est-ce qu'elle a du sens que vous allez
voir le truc est vraiment super on y va
maintenant
neiges et secourir c'est très
intéressant et c'est une solution vous
risquerez de retrouver chez vous quand
vous entrez dans vos produits high tech
et ça justement qui votait brice pitié
alors je peux nous expliquer un petit
peu quel est votre boîte
quel est votre produit payé votre techno
et qu'est ce que vous faites alors
énergie square on a développé une
technologie de charge pour 10 appareils
électroniques
jeanne d'arc collection
un côté comme ça qui est professeur
jacques ça sert qu'à l'ère blanc de
carey métalliques etc avec nos lecteurs
avec sans rogner sur fa cup
on met sur son téléphone petite auto
goal com succès ici
voilà sur cet autocollant il ya deux
électrodes
ces deux petits points 2
elles seront liées à la batterie à
travers
boîtier main
qu'on le pose sur le pad il va y avoir
un contact physique direct contre 6
électrodes et de carrick on exhorte à la
conduction au caire le téléphone ou
et à charger et
on voit l'énergie de gens directement
pour la chaleur
ça va permettre de recharger tout les
appareils en même temps sur cette phase
3 4 est compatible avec nos sous
chez soi des iphone
un petit post on suppose qu'on
smartphone sur le pad ou n'importe où
n'importe où alors ce qu'on m'explique
tout à l'heure c'est qu'effectivement
c'est prévu à ce que les deux
connecteurs qui sont là depuis ce matin
même qu'elle s'est toujours sur deux cas
différents et une case qui s'adonnent
qui détecte le téléphone qui va
et le reste à 0 point et non fiables
le circuit se ferment et convoyés
d'énergie
ok cool alors
donc l'idée c'est que tu peut recharger
différents appareils dessus du corps
chargés aussi j'ai lu sur un ordinateur
portable
oui alors on
travailler sur une version qui s'intègre
directement dans les meubles
l'appareil un maillage conducteur sur le
meuble est un petit sticker un peu comme
sur le modeste mais pour ordinateurs
portables
et donc proposant des affaires
comptables sur son perron qu'elles
recherchent ou d'un plugin câble pour
que quand il faut s'alimenter
intéressant alors l'idée du produit elle
vient elle dit redouter cette techno
cette innovation l'idée
se dire jamais
si on veut pouvoir garder
son téléphone axant son sens
90 ans au pouvoir chargé par tous les
sens et qu'on sait et on s'est calé sur
un usage contact vous apparaissez suite
de mettre sur nos tables tenu de lancer
un peu partout ce conte référent
utiliser ce temps là pour l'absorber
et du coup il fallait pouvoir charger
sur une surface entière c'est pour ça
qu'on est parti sur cette technologie
conductible qui est pas encore là
c'est pourquoi
c'est pas tellement
d'accord c'est vraiment super parce que
du coup sûr une casse comme ça n'a pas
changé comme un départ et non mettre
quatre ou cinq de table et vous
constaterez que ma foi c'est une
question de volume j'imagine est encore
chargé d alors les bons collectivement
parce qu'il faut forcément branché sur
sa prise électrique à l'origine question
si j'ai causé était à tes côtés
resteront postes par rapport à
l'induction
comment vous positionnez parce qu'on va
très bien qu'aujourd'hui d'entreprise
entreprise comme apple comme samsung et
d'autres
vraiment se positionner sur le marché de
l'industrie
vous par rapport à ce marché là comment
se positionne votre techno alors sur ce
produit là
des personnes qui ont des besoins
spécifiques et qui peuvent pas se
contenter de charger en un an
on sait par exemple des entreprises qui
ont soufflé deux tablettes
pression de la tête à positionner la
tablette tu
dîner maîtrise
lalancette a changé
fabricants d'appareils électroniques ou
accros de cibler des appareils qui
peuvent s'intégrer l'injection
des objets qu'ils entendent plus
d'énergie des perceuses des power tout
au sol des objets comme des cigarettes
avec unis qui ont
métallique qui peut pas intégrer sur ce
lac aux policiers ok alors du coup vous
et
vendée directement auprès du particulier
où passait vraiment soir professionnels
alors aujourd'hui on a été une campagne
qui se tapper
la naissance unités de l'épreuve
l'egypte est un surnom
et eux
les produits qui ont été produits en
plus
professionnels et à terme
2.12 familiale
la technologie cette exigence qui avait
plu
faites tout ce tintamarre
enfin c'est super intéressant alors le
côté j'en parlais tout à l'heure changer
de plan de travail intense avec pour que
apple se dirigent dessus élections
alors après jc sur des produits qui sont
vraiment très spécifiques
dès qu'apple là ont beaucoup m pu
changer tous les smartphones qui est
tout seul on va plus escarpés
on a les stickers et on en a pour au
micro usb usb tous ses week-ends se
développer et le lightning
voyons les anciens modèles d'iphone qui
avait pas
donc c'est un produit qu'on ne peut pas
acheter nous directement sans votre
single mais ça va venir dans les
prochaines semaines ok
est-ce que tu as une adresse du site web
ou si l'un de nous annoncer ww pour nrj
avec les grecs ont reculé
je suis tout mettre dans la description
que vous trouvez ça c'est facilement
vous inquiétez pas ok qu'est ce que tu
vois un truc elle ajouté
[Musique]
question piège si jamais voilà est-ce
qu'il ya des points quand on ne va pas
parler par rapport à la techno en
elle-même marché alors produit sur
lequel on travaille c'est le même pas un
métier une patrie infectés et des
panneaux solaires et
c'est un pack qui est complètement
autonome aussi rédacteur en chef
price un pad autonomes ont d'autres
marchés ou
maintenant
et on peut le refaire
ça tu es aussi patricia
génial et vous avez aujourd'hui notre
succès
m après
le 14 mai encore plus disponible
cela tient aussi beaucoup
longue vie aux cotisations super c'est
nous il faut ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que des systèmes de recharge par
production - vous intéresser mettez moi
tout ça en commentaire pendant discuter
ensemble vous ai dit bien évidemment à
laisser tomber des jolies pousse à vous
abonner à rester policiers parce qu'on
va parler toujours plus d'entreprises
françaises innovantes
merci beaucoup merci à bientôt
[Musique]